let's all bank worldwide raising phenom  Danny su for coming up with the idea for  today's competition Danny su he's very  confident she's a racing star she  friends of the gang thanks Mickey y'all  did great she's a very happy spirited  person that is really excited to help  Dallas her dog very well yeah let's get  your ball and go I wanted to be part of  Mickey in the roaster racers because I  of course watched Mickey Mouse growing  up Danny I can't wait for you to visit  hot dog Hills again  thanks knew is kind of like the hyper  happy version of Danica Sue I actually  wish I could be a little bit more like  Danny super wealthy it sure will be fun  watching y'all try to beat us  similarities between myself and Danny  too we both have a miniature Siberian  Husky named Alice there's a lot of funny  report I'll be back  especially now the gels made a bunch of  new friends  you  [Music]